AND NOW IT'S TIME FOR OUR NEXT
GAME, TECHROTICA.
TECHROTICA.
HEY, EROTICA FANS, I IF YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR PERFECT MARRIAGE OF
HARD DICK'S AND HARD DISKS LOOK
NO FURTHER THAN THE WORKS OF
LEONARD DELANEY. HE IS A SELF
PUBLISHED AMAZON AUTHOR WITH A
TOTALLY NOT FAKE NAME WHO WRITES
TECH BASED EROTIC STORIES LIKE
THE NEW KINDLE BOOK "INVADED BY
THE IWATCH," VERY TIMELY HERE.
I'M JUST GUESSING HERE BUT I BET
THAT WATCH GIVES OUT HOT WET
STEVE JOBS.
HIS OTHER BOOKS IN THE DIGITAL
DESIRES SERIES INCLUDE "TAKEN BY
THE TETRIS BLOCKS" AND
"CONQUERED BY CLIPPY."
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE BEGINNING
TO PLEASURE YOURSELF.
CAN I TO HELP YOU WITH THAT?
CLEARLY TECH PORN IS HUGE
UNAPPED DICK MARKET SO COMEDIANS
COME UP WITH AS MANY MORE
TECH-ROTICA TITLES AS YOU CAN
UNTIL I CLIMAX IN 60-SECONDS.
GO!
ANNIE.
>> G-SPOTIFY: A PLAYLIST TO
[BLEEP] BY.
>> Chris: POINTS.
AL.
>> MENAGE A DOS.
>> Chris: POINTS. JIM.
>> DRAG QUEEN AND DROP QUEEN.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS.
ANNIE.
>> BINARY CURIOUS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JIM.
>> THUMB-DRIVING MS. DAISY.
>> Chris: POINTS!
ANNIE.
>> IBM, THEN UBM.
>> Chris: POINTS.
THEY MUST'VE THOUGHT OF THAT AT
SOME POINT AT THAT COMAPNY!
THEY HAVE BEEN AROUND FOR
DECADES.
JIM.
>> PANDORA'S BOX.
>> Chris: YES.
ANNIE.
>> JUST DON'T GET IT IN MY
iPHONE
>> Chris: POINTS.
AL.
>> FACEBUKKAKI.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JIM.
>> ARE YOU A LAPTOP OR
LAPBOTTOM?
>> Chris: YES, POINTS.